[Applaus]
[Musik]
große Aufregung weiter um den
Putschversuch aus Ministerin der
bärbock-verband Bismarck aus ihren
Ministerium und immer mehr Deutsche sind
psychische am Ende brauchen Hilfe wir
haben viel zu besprechen hier mit diesen
Gästen
gewaltpräventionsexperte Carsten Stahl
sagt er könnte noch leben die 14-Jährige
wurde jetzt zu Grabe getragen sie wurde
erstochen auf dem Schulweg von einem
Asylbewerber wie konnte das passieren
und wir sprechen über den pannenwahntag
heute in Deutschland wurden sie gewarnt
oder haben bei Ihnen die Sirenen auch
nicht geheult FDP-Politiker BJ so sagt
wir können vom Glück sagen dass es heute
nur eine Übung war
autoschutz der Flughäfen funktioniert
nicht heute wieder klimakleber auf den
Rollbahnen in München und in Berlin
Polizistin Birgit Kelle fordert endlich
härtere Strafen das immer mehr Menschen
unter Depressionen und Ängsten leiden
das weiß der Psychologe und Autor Rolf
Schmiel die Menschen werden so oft
alleine gelassen brauchen dringend mehr
Hilfe sagt er das alles unsere Themen
Otto von Bismarck hat das Auswärtige Amt
gegründet führte die fortschrittlichsten
Sozialgesetze der Welt ein gilt aber
auch als Wegbereiter des deutschen
Kolonialismus er galt nicht es Demokrat
der frühere Reichskanzler ist aber Teil
der deutschen Geschichte aber nicht mehr
das Auswärtigen Amtes das bismarckzimmer
wird umbenannt heißt jetzt sei der
deutschen Einheit auch das Porträt des
einzigen Reichskanzlers wurde abgehängt
darüber sprechen wir jetzt hier Frau
Keller wollen damit die Grünen unsere
Geschichte bereinigen sie sind ja schon
dabei es ist ja nicht das erste Mal dass
aus der Öffentlichkeit sagen wir mal
Geschichte oder eben auch Tradition
verbannt wird wir haben zuletzt die
Diskussion über das Humboldt Schloss
über die Bibel Inschrift die ja auch
historisch einfach dort ist wir haben
bei denen die sieben Treffen haben wir
einen historisches Kreuz aus einem Saal
getragen obwohl sich gar niemand
beschwert hat das heißt wir sind schon
dabei im Endeffekt unsere gesamte
Tradition und das ist die christlich
abendländische Tradition
auch die Straßennamen übrigens ja es ist
ja auch jetzt ist ja nicht das erste Mal
dass wir auch quasi das Thema
Kolonialismus meinen löschen zu müssen
auch die Umbenennung ganz vieler Straßen
gehört mit in dieses Konzept hinein und
insofern geschichtslöschung muss ich
sagen ist ein ganz seltsames Gefühl
kommt da auf weil nur totalitäre Regime
haben das bislang gemacht weltweit dass
sie versucht haben die eigene Geschichte
zu eliminieren und sie neu zu schreiben
diese Tendenz muss eigentlich sofort
gestoppt werden als Begründung heißt es
ja man wolle der historischen
Entwicklung des Raumes Rechnung tragen
da fragt man sich was ist daran falsch
man will nicht die Rechnung tragen der
Historie sondern man will die Historie
löschen das ist eine völlig andere
Ambition also man könnte ja sich darüber
unterhalten irgendwie was
aber allerdings über viele Politiker die
Frage ist dann auch wie weit will man
zurückgeben also welchen Teil der
Geschichte will man löschen nach welchen
Kriterien wer ist im Rückblick überhaupt
noch adäquat hier ist selber werden
unsere Kinder uns in 50 Jahren auch
löschen weil wir es falsch gemacht haben
ehrlich sagen wir können auch aus
Geschichte nicht lernen wenn wir die
Geschichte eliminieren normalerweise
lernt man daraus indem man an die
Geschichte erinnert sie aufarbeitet also
eine Frage was würde passieren wenn
jetzt plötzlich eine wie eine Regierung
haben die sagte wir löschen den
Holocaust aus dem Gedächtnis der
Deutschen weil es ist ja jetzt auch
genug und das waren ja sowieso
Verbrecher und wir wollen die eigentlich
gar nicht mehr in unserem historischen
Gedächtnis haben sondern wir machen
jetzt mal Schlussstrich dann wäre der
Aufschrei groß zu Recht ja dass man sagt
wo ist der Unterschied nach welchen
Kriterien wird hier gelöscht und ich
stelle fest dass vor allen Dingen das
christlich christliche Abendland raus
gelöscht wird das ist eine große
Diskussion derzeit Herr Stahl wenn sie
hören dass die Politiker so ein Thema
auf die Agenda setzen wie man das Zimmer
jetzt benennen sollte das ist nicht mehr
bis Marke Zimmer heißt was geht ihnen
dadurch den Kopf dass das überhaupt
jetzt eine Rolle spielt gibt es nicht
wichtigere Probleme fragt man sich aber
die Politik auf einem grünen und auf dem
linken Auge blind ist und nur ihr
ideologischen Interessen folgt da
wundert mich gar nichts mehr meine man
kann über Bismarck mit Sicherheit
diskutieren aber ich glaube nicht dass
er Bücher gefälscht hat lebensläufige
feldstadt meine Frau Bärbel möchte ja
auch vor vielem Anlagen ablenken ich
hoffe bloß irgendwann dass wir auch mal
diese grüne Geschichte die sich jetzt
hier gerade in unserem Land breit macht
dieser Gründer Sozialismus der hier
durchs Land getragen wird dass der auch
irgendwann mal aus unseren Verstand
gelöscht wird oder anders wann
entwickeln wir eigentlich wieder unseren
Verstand und schreien mal auf und sagen
es reicht wenn das was da passiert ist
unerträglich unsäglich aber das war
lange nicht die Spitze des Eisberges sie
werden immer weitermachen und setzen
darauf dass die Menschen das entweder
mitmachen oder sich vollkommen verblöten
lassen also ganz ehrlich ich frag mich
warum ist eigentlich keiner von diesen
Politikern hier und erklärt uns das mal
ganz einfach weil sie genau wissen dass
sie keine Erklärung für diesen
Schwachsinn haben aber sie machen ihn
weiter die Frage ist ob wir es weiter
ertragen und Mitmachen ich mache dabei
garantiert nicht weiter damit habe ich
sowieso nicht aber das liegt ja bei
selbst ob er das gut findet und wie die
Politik da aufschreibt aber wir haben
garantiert wichtigere Probleme
schlimmere Probleme als diesen Mist den
sie da verzapfen aber dass er ablenken
wollen und sich wichtig tun wollen das
wissen wir doch alle werden die Politik
hier am Tisch mit sitzen wir wollen
zumindest sie fragen ist die Politik
dazu abgehoben erweckt man damit den
Eindruck dass man gar nicht die
wichtigen Probleme gerade auf der Agenda
hat ich glaube schon das ist bei großen
Teilen der grünen Politik auch eine
abgewohnheit gibt dass man mit den
echten Problemen draußen nichts mehr zu
tun haben will das ist ja auch eine
Elfenbeinturm Diskussion und wenn man
sich diesen Geschichtsrevisionismus
anguckt dass man einfach Teile der
deutschen Geschichte aus dem
öffentlichen Bewusstsein raushalten will
das ist ja auch eine Tendenz Frau Keller
zu Recht gesagt da wird einer kritischen
Auseinandersetzung jeder Boden entzogen
denn es wird einfach ein Teil unserer
Geschichte gelöscht und ich persönlich
kann nicht nachvollziehen warum unsere
Außenministerin in bundeseigenen
Gebäuden ein solchen Weg wählt zumal ja
sie auch jetzt nicht gesagt hat es wären
andere Persönlichkeit vielleicht besser
geeignet als Bismarck sondern das ganze
dann zum Saal der deutschen Einheit zu
machen das kann doch keiner mehr
nachvollziehen also mir fehlt da jedes
Verständnis für so eine Geschichte es
ist ja auch so dass die Grünen in den
Ländern auch hier in Berlin ständig
Straßen umbenennen
Kolonialismus zu Recht anprangern aber
eben dann aus dem öffentlichen
Bewusstsein aus der Stadt löschen ohne
dass diese kritische Auseinandersetzung
stattfinden und das ist ein großes
Problem
das macht es mit den Menschen kriegt man
da irgendwie so eine Art Schere auch in
den Kopf dass es Dinge gibt manche haben
das Gefühl es gab diese Studie auch man
darf gar nicht mehr das sagen man traut
sich gewisse Dinge nicht zu sagen was
macht das mit den Menschen psychologisch
ist eine weitere Verunsicherung und wir
sind in so vielen Punkten schon
verunsichert und sehr dünnhäutig
geworden jetzt weiß man nichtmals mehr
ob man sich ein Bismarckhering
wahrscheinlich beizeiten bestellen darf
weil das wahrscheinlich auch ein
unangemessener Begriff ist dazu bestellt
das heißt also hier haben wir eine große
Herausforderung dass Menschen weiter vor
uns wird wenn in Dingen die vertraut
waren und umso weniger vertraut es wir
haben umso größer ist die Belastung mit
einem neuen das heißt wir brauchen da
ein emotionales Gegengewicht und das
wird genommen und damit stürzen wir
viele Menschen immer weiter in eine
Krise das trägt also sagen sie zur
Verunsicherung weil man fragt sich auch
wo ist dann die Grenze also wo sagen wir
das aber jetzt mal Schluss das gehört zu
unserer deutschen Geschichte dazu damit
wollen wir uns auch auseinandersetzen wo
ziehen Sie sie da die Grenze ich glaube
das
Adolf hitler-platz den es in Berlin ja
auch gab oder Hermann Göring oder
ähnliches dass man das jetzt ausreichend
kritisch auch im Unterricht behandelt
dass auch jeder glaube ich deutsche die
Gelegenheit hat sich darüber zu
informieren wenn er denn oder sie möchte
aber da würde ich schon sagen das
brauchen wir tatsächlich in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht da gibt es eine
hinreichende kritische
Auseinandersetzung aber gerade die
koloniale Vergangenheit Deutschlands
gerade eben auch das Deutsche Reich als
solches das sind alles Dinge mit denen
kann man sich denke ich auch kritisch
nachträglich auseinandersetzen das muss
man nicht löschen den
Nationalsozialismus darf man nicht
löschen und den Rest der Geschichte darf
man auch nicht löschen und deswegen
glaube ich sollten wir viel mehr die
kritische Auseinandersetzung suchen auch
die Grünen müssen lernen sich mit
anderen Meinungen auseinanderzusetzen
weil es ist ja der Meinungs Pluralismus
in der Gesellschaft der das Wesentliche
ist das Interessantes dabei
das ja auch die grüne Versuchung ihre
Pädophile politische Vergangenheit zu
löschen dass da keiner drüber redet was
sie in den neuen Jahr noch gefordert
haben Sex mit Kindern zu legalisieren
wollen wir das doch mal nicht vergessen
und wie weit haben Sie sich denn davon
weg bewegt im letzten Jahr haben wir
viel Gesetze zum Schutz der Kinder vor
kindesmissbrauchen die Bundestag
getragen und ich war daran beteiligt
Kinder Sexpuppen verboten Handbuch für
Pädophile verboten einen Tag ins
Führungszeugnis für Kinder lebenslang
und
Kinderpornografie zu Verbrechen so viel
dazu aber es waren zwei Parteien
darunter die Grünen und auch eine andere
Partei der sie angehören die sich den
Gesetzen bei der Abstimmung enthalten
haben und da frage ich mich natürlich
gelernt aus seiner pädophilen
Vergangenheit wenn man gesetzlich
zumindest missbraucht ich habe jetzt die
Vorhaben natürlich im einzelnen nicht
auf dem Schirm das muss ich einräumen
aber es ist natürlich so wenn wir uns
enthalten haben im Bundestag dann gibt's
dafür höchstwahrscheinlich einen guten
Grund nämlich dass das Anliegen
grundsätzlich unterstützenswert war
sonst würde man sich nicht enthalten
sondern dagegen stimmen aber das ist
wahrscheinlich handwerkliche
Schwierigkeiten gehabt das wäre der
Grund warum normalerweise nur
Enthaltungen im Bundestag stattfindet
also ich sag mal wahrscheinlich gab es
eine Einigkeit in der Zielrichtung aber
im Einzelnen oder in den Details
wahrscheinlich bei den Grünen gab es
keine Einigkeit so viel kann ich nicht
sagen gut dann ist das verständlich ich
glaube das nachdem es eigentlich das
überhaupt Menschen oder Politiker oder
eine Regierungsmitglieder glauben sie
hätten das Recht Geschicht zu löschen im
Nachhinein das ist eigentlich das
Grundproblem also woher kommt diese
Ambition also woher kommt ein denken
dass man glaubt man habe das Recht
historische Ereignisse für ungeschehen
zu erklären oder Personen für nicht also
für nicht existent zu erklären um sie
aus dem kollektiven Gedächtnis zu
löschen und das sehr schön nein es ist
aber genau das wie soll ich sagen wenn
Sie den Gründer also Bismarck ist ja
nicht irgendjemand im Auswärtigen Amt
sondern der Gründer des Auswärtigen
Amtes dass sie also man ist quasi dabei
den Gründer dieses Hauses aus dem Haus
zu verbannt entschuldigung das hat schon
einen einen ganz schönen beige Geschmack
ähm
das ist eine Ambition die man schlicht
untergreifend sagen wir mal unter
normalen in freiheitlichen
Gesellschaften sollte es überhaupt gar
keine Ambition geben Historie
ungeschehen also sozusagen aus dem aus
dem Bewusstsein der Menschen zu löschen
und das ist es ja im Endeffekt also
gerade eine Regierung wie die Grünen die
Grünen sind ja diejenigen die immer
sagen es ginge um visibility wenn es um
andere Themen geht die Sichtbarkeit der
Frau die Sichtbarkeit der Vielfalt der
Geschlechter dann kann man jetzt sagen
im Umkehrschluss machen sie gerade
Bismarck unsichtbar also sie machen und
deswegen weiß man eben auch sie machen
es sehr bewusst weil sie sonst nämlich
genau sehr großen Wert darauf legen dass
Dinge die Ihnen wichtig sind in der
Öffentlichkeit sichtbar sind im
Regierungsprogramm sichtbar sind und
hier werden jetzt Dinge gelöscht hier
werden Bibelzitate gelöscht hier werden
Kreuze abgehängt hier werden Personen
aus dem aus dem historischen Gedächtnis
gelöscht und mit verlobt das ist
totalitär sie haben angesprochen Themen
sichtbar machen wir wollen hier eines
sichtbar machen und darüber reden wir
jetzt mit Carsten Stahl wir wollen
sprechen über ätsche 14 Jahre alte
stochen auf dem Weg zur Schule in
Baden-Württemberg sie sagen dieses
Mädchen Teenager die keine Zukunft mehr
es hat sie hätte noch leben können ja
sie hätte noch leben können und sie
immer noch leben wenn eine Politik
gehandelt hätte wie viele von ihnen
wissen oder der ein oder andere nicht
ich bin eine bekanntesten Kinderschützer
in Deutschland und aufgrund meiner
Arbeit mit Millionen von Menschen die
die begleiten und verfolgen bekomme ich
viele Hilfe und ich habe direkt nach
diesem Mord an etsche ein Video gemacht
und habe da sehr klare deutliche Worte
gefunden und dann haben wir auch
Menschen aus dieser Stadt geschrieben
aus diesem kleinen Ort in der Kirche
oder in der Kirchberg und haben mir
Dinge gesagt Dinge die bekannt waren und
jetzt noch öffentlich werden und die
öffentlich machen werden auch in BILD am
SONNTAG und noch andere Medien Dinge die
man komischerweise in anderen Medien
nicht erfährt so wurde schon im Sommer
diesen Jahres immer wieder die Stadt der
Bürgermeister auch hingewiesen dass da
Übergriffe waren Kinder auch verfolgt
wurden belästigt wurden von diesen
Menschen die dort auch in diesem
Wohnheim waren und ob der jetzt der eine
oder andere psychisch krank war oder
nicht das soll jetzt erstmal
dahingestellt sein aber es wurde nichts
getan man hat es ignoriert und ich habe
hier eine klare Botschaft wie viele
Menschen müssen noch sterben wie viele
Menschen müssen noch für eine
Migrationspolitik die nicht funktioniert
ihr Leben lassen wie viele Menschen
müssen hier noch
Opfer werden mir persönlich ist es ganz
egal woher jemand kommt welche Religion
er hat welche welche Kultur er hat denn
mir geht es um die Menschen um jedes
Leben und hier ist ein Mädchen mit
türkischem Hintergrund zu Tode gekommen
erstochen worden getötet worden und ein
anderes Schwert verletzt worden und
wieder geht's nur darum ganz schnell
entweder wie sich hinzustellen und
sozusagen was wir zu denken haben und
wieder mit der Nazi Keule zu winken
machtlos den Mund auf dann haben wir
drauf ich rede darüber und zwar habe ich
gesagt in Gedanken an Frankfurt in
Gedanken Ludwigshafen und jetzt in
Gedanken in der Kirchberg in Gedenken an
hätte und er mir denken an jedem
Menschen der in unserem Land durch eine
Politik mit zu Tode kommt die nicht
Präsident dass wenn man Menschen nicht
integriert sie nicht aufhängt einfängt
und vor allen Dingen den man sie
unkontrolliert ins Land holt ohne zu
schauen welche Probleme sie schon
mittragen welche Gewalt oder welche
Kriminalität sie schon mittragen oder ob
sie krank sind hierhin lässt und damit
die ganze Gesellschaft jeden Menschen
jede Kultur jeder Religion in Gefahr
bringt dieses kleine Mädchen könnte noch
leben übrigens genauso wie Leonie dessen
Mutter mit mir in Kontakt steht und wo
jetzt die Täter lebenslang und 19 und 20
Jahre bekommen hat in Wien und wir
vertreten die Eltern mit dabei um das
Land und Wien mit zu verklagen und auch
Österreich mit zur verladen und genau
das muss bei uns auch passieren wir
müssen die Politik in Regress nehmen wir
müssen hier auch dafür sorgen sie tragen
die Verantwortung dafür wenn sie
Menschen unser Land holen und nicht
kontrollieren die schmeißen ihre Pässe
weg und sagen sie sind 12 oder 14 und 30
was stimmt ja nicht könnte man
überprüfen will man sich überprüfen nein
aber vorweg
meine Kinder sind polnisch meine
Freundin hat muslimischen Hintergrund
und ich habe mehr türkischer arabische
Freunde als Deutsche und viele Menschen
schreien hier auf mit
Migrationshintergrund das ist keine
Frage welcher politischen Agenda man
angehört und jetzt wollte die AFD sich
auch hinstellen und schreiben auch was
passiert denn hier alle haben hier
versagt aber die Frage ist wie viele
Menschen müssen noch sterben wir müssen
die Menschen integrieren wir müssen sie
kontrollieren und wenn Menschen wie hier
um Hilfe rufen Herr Bürgermeister und
sie ignorieren dann tragen Sie eine mit
Schuld und jetzt brauchen Sie sich nicht
vertuschen und es muss sich der ZDF
sagen oh das ist wieder wertig ein Mord
aber auch das zu instrumentalisieren
widerwärtlich ist ein Mord wieder werde
ich und asoziales eine Politik die nur
ihren Interessen dient und die Bürger im
still ist alle Bürger egal welcher
Religion schützt die BürgerInnen jeden
einzelnen jedes Leben ist wertvoll und
es reicht was hier abläuft es war wenn
dieses Thema hochemotional sind wir
gestartet weil wir aber einmal tiefer
eintauchen Frau Kelle was kann man tun
damit solche alle möglichst nicht
passieren sagen wir es mal so wir haben
doch überhaupt nichts getan um insofern
haben wir die ist die ist die ist die
Spanne von dem was wir tun können extrem
hoch und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
habe auch eine 14-Jährige die morgens
das Haus verlässt und zur Schule geht
und ich möchte dass sie halt wieder nach
Hause kommt und ich möchte gar nicht in
einem Land leben wo ich mir Sorgen
machen muss und ich schreibe jetzt
selber auch als Publizistin seit seit
der migrationskrise 2015 muss ich mich
als Rassistin beschimpfen lassen weil
ich schon damals gesagt habe das was auf
der Kölner Domplatte passiert ist ist
ein zugewandertes Problem das ist ein
Problem dass wir vorher nicht hatten und
das heißt dieses Problem ist eigentlich
seit Beginn der migrationskrise bekannt
ja es ist nicht das erste Mädchen das
tot ist und schon gar nicht ist es das
erste Mädchen das vielleicht
vergewaltigt wurde wir haben eine wir
haben so viele sexuelle Übergriffe
eigentlich müsste jeder anständige
Feministin auf den Barrikaden sein in
Deutschland und gerade auch die Leute
die jetzt gerade in der Regierung sind
gerade auf die Grünen die sonst
irgendwie in diesem Thema immer ganz
vorne dabei sind ja alle schweigen
darüber niemand will dieses Fass
aufmachen wir haben gerade läuft im
Moment die Islamkonferenz in Deutschland
wir reden aber nicht über das Problem
über das problematische ist er
muslimische Frauenbild zum Beispiel ja
also unsere Innenministerin fährt nach
nach Katar um dort die Frauenrechte und
die Schwulenrechte zu retten aber findet
keine Worte hier in Deutschland
angesichts dessen was hier Frauen Hass
und Schwulen hat stattfindet von
demselben Klientel ja das heißt wir
retten die Welt irgendwo in Katar aber
wir stellen uns nicht den Problemen hier
und ich empfinde das gerade auch Frauen
gegenüber als unmöglich in diesem Land
weil Frauen und eben die jungen Mädchen
sind sozusagen die leichtesten Opfer ja
und wir sehen es ja auch immer wieder ja
wir sehen immer wieder dass das die
Frauen betrifft und sobald man auf das
Thema aufmerksam macht dann heißt es
dann kommt sofort die Rassismus Keule
und dann heißt es irgendwie man das ist
eine eine Täter Opfer Umkehr die hier
passiert und ähm wir sind bereit in
diesem Land jedes jedes Wort eines alten
diesen weißen Mannes gegen eine Frau
irgendwie auf eine Goldwaage zu legen
aber wenn wir Übergriffe haben von
jungen schwarzen Männern um es mal als
Kontrast aufzubauen dann gucken alle weg
dann gucken alle weg und der erste
Schritt der wäre in meinen Augen wir
erstens mal dass wir diese Grenzen
schließen das ist das erste was wir
machen müssen dass wir erstmal
kontrollieren wer kommt in dieses Land
und hat er überhaupt den Anspruch und
ist er wirklich Flüchtling und so weiter
das heißt wir müssen wissen wer es ist
und zweitens müssen wir alle
rausschmeißen die illegal hier sind ja
ich verstehe es nicht und ich bin auch
nicht mehr bereit hier Menschen
sozusagen zu dulden in diesem Land die
Straftaten begehen und trotzdem nicht
ausgewiesen werden das ist auch der
Menschen nicht mehr klar zu machen warum
wir würden Ärger bekommen mit dem Gesetz
wenn wir anfangen auch nur falsche
Angaben irgendwie auf dem einwohnermelde
waren zu machen zu unserer eigenen
Person warum wir sind zu einer Witzfigur
geworden weltweit wir laden die Leute
ein wir kontrollieren nichts und wir
legen an unsere eigen den Bürger
strengere Gesetze an als an die Menschen
die angebliche herkommen nur weil sie
unsere Hilfe wollen
der soll sich wie ein Gast Benehmen eben
gerade hat Carsten Stahl das auch
angesprochen hat gesagt die Menschen die
kommen die werden auch alleine gelassen
die werden das ist das große Problem sie
werden kommen vielleicht mit einem
Trauma hier an mit einer Vergangenheit
die wir nicht kennen und sitzen dann in
einer Unterkunft und werden nicht
betreut sie als Psychologin da steht man
noch in der Verantwortung
erschütternd wofür in Deutschland Geld
vorhanden ist und wofür kein Geld
vorhanden ist und wenn man den Wunsch
als ein solches geistliches Land zu sein
dann muss man sich mit den Risiken was
schwere kriegst Traumata mit sich
bringen einfach auch bewusst werden da
kann man jeden Experten fragen das
bestimmte Frustration auch erschüttern
eine eigene Traumatisierung und auch ein
bestimmtes damit verbundenes Frauenbild
leider zu Übergriffen und Brutalitäten
der Art und Weise führen kann muss auch
sagen es trifft ja nicht jeden der hier
hin kommt der so drauf ist aber alles
kann passieren und deshalb haben wir
eine Verantwortung dafür zu sorgen wo
diese Potenziale da sind mit Profis zu
arbeiten entweder Dinge zu leiten dass
es besser wird oder aber auch zu
erkennen wir haben hier eine Gefährdung
der Gesellschaft wenn ein fremd und
Selbstgefährdung vorhanden ist weil das
von mir ausgeht dann werde ich
eingewiesen in anderen Fällen fragt man
sich das nicht mal sich einer dafür
interessiert es interessiert sich keiner
dafür was in den Heimen stattfindet es
geht keiner hin sie können gerne
antworten nimmt der Starter seiner
Verantwortung wahr wir starten nimmt
Verantwortung wahr aber nicht in
ausreichendem Maß also hier muss man ja
ganz klar sagen es ist ein schrecklicher
Fall der symptomatisch ist für einige
Fälle die aufgetreten sind in gleicher
Weise und wenn man da schon ein musste
erkennt ja dann kann also man kann ja
sagen wenn es ein Einzelfall wäre ist es
nicht dann wäre es dann wäre es ja so
eine Sache über die man reden könnte
aber hier gibt's einen Muster und eine
ganz klare Tendenz und deswegen ist auch
der Stadt hier in der Verantwortung auch
die Politik ist da ganz kleine erfahren
ist ja richtig was sie sagen der Staat
der integrieren will der muss auch
Integrationsleistung zulassen und auch
selber erbringen ich bin nicht ganz bei
Ihnen Frau Kelle ich glaube schon dass
ein Staat wie Deutschland eine gewisse
Verantwortung hat auch im Rahmen des
internationalen Völkerrechts es ist ja
so dass die jungen Menschen die aus der
Ukraine beispielsweise zu uns kommen
junge Mädchen die dort praktisch aus
Kriegsgebieten fliehen dass wir den
Schutz gewähren das ist auch völlig in
Ordnung
wir müssen diese Grenze soweit schließen
dass wir erstmal kontrollieren wir
reinkommen ich will das an dieser Stelle
nochmal sagen es ist auch richtig dass
einige
bevölkerungs-bereiche dort zu uns kommen
das sind auch Menschen die Schutz
verdienen und das müssen wir im Auge
behalten aber wir müssen auch unsere
eigene Bevölkerung schützen und das ist
die Verantwortung
die spreche jetzt hier nicht als
deutscher Bürger der christliche
Glauben angehört oder besser sagte ich
habe meinen eigenen Glauben aber ich
rede für alle ich spreche auch für viele
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund und
das ist es entscheiden ich habe viele
tolle Menschen wir es kommen auch
Menschen untereinander die unser Land
bereichern aber es kommen nun mal auch
Menschen die unser Land gefährden wir
hatten alleine im Jahre 2020 über 720
Gruppen Vergewaltigung und dann kann man
genau sehen wenn man sich anguckt seit
wann der ein oder anderen unser Land ist
so heißt das dass jeder unser Land
kommen vergewaltigt ist natürlich nicht
und übrigens wurden ja nicht nur muss
deutsche oder christliche Frauen so eine
asiatische mit migrationshelferin
jeglicher Art und Weise also müssen wir
schützen genauso ich verlange von der
Bundesregierung dass sie die Messe
Attacken offen legt wie viele und wer
vor allen Dingen die Messerattacken
macht das wird schön gerne und natürlich
gekehrt das sind genau diese Probleme
wenn wir in Berlin Anfragen stellen das
hatte ich ja schon ein paar mal gesagt
zum Beispiel Gewalt an Schulen unter
Verschluss Sache wir wollten wissen wenn
die Verantwortung Experiment sind und
wer noch in die Internet
und genauso ist es hier der
Bürgermeister die natürlich alle hier in
meinen Augen haben die Blut an ihren
Händen und nochmal wir reden hier von
Würzburg in Frankfurt dieser Junge
hingeschubst wurde auf der Bahn wo die
Mutter ist immer wieder der gleiche
Muster und die hört mir auf mit dieser
Verlogenheit das wären Einzelfälle und
immer wenn man sagt kommen sie wieder so
wie jetzt der Herr vom ZDF der sagt
widerwärtig wenn man es
instrumentalisierte instrumentalisiert
niemand was aber wer die Realität nicht
sehen will lässt zu dass es wieder
passiert und ich möchte alle Kinder alle
Menschen unser Land schützen vor den
Gefahren und wer hier ins Land kommt hat
sich an die Regeln zu halten und ein
Arschloch ist ein Arschloch egal in
welcher Kultur wenn er diese regelrecht
muss halt Knast oder wenn er nicht mehr
tragbar ist muss er auch ausgewiesen
werden die weißen nichts aus im
Gegenteil sie holen noch mehr rein und
das darf nicht unkontrolliert Geschehen
ich will wissen wer ins Land kommt und
wenn sie sagen ich habe keinen Pass man
kann heute anhand Knochen Analyse
feststellen wie alt ist wird nicht
gemacht man geht in Geld man geht in
Unterkunft und dann lässt man sich
selbst so fördert man keine Migration so
fördert
gerade sagt jetzt mit all den
Hintergrund die wir hier auch
zusammentragen eine gute Idee die Hürden
für einen deutschen Pass noch zu senken
ja das kommt darauf an für welche
Personengruppen sicherlich nicht für
gefährliche Gewalttäter die hier
schwerste Kriminalität begehen auch
nicht für andere ich will aber das
Augenmerk noch mal auf die Frage lenken
wie wir mit solchen Bevölkerungsgruppen
umgehen ich war sehr irritiert ich habe
das jetzt in Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus
Senat gesehen wir haben ja eine Gruppe
von Menschen aus Moldawien hier in
Berlin die eigentlich
ausreisepflichtig sind und die auch
abgeschoben werden soll und es hat
tatsächlich der Berliner Senat gegen den
Widerstand der inselnatorin übrigens
beschlossen dass die alle hier bleiben
können obwohl die teilweise straffällig
sind und das ist ein Punkt wo ich mich
frage was machen Linke und Grüne an der
stelle ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen
da bin ich voll bei ihm sowas kann es in
einer Demokratie nicht geben weil wir
sind ja auch den Menschen hier
verantwortlich ja und das ist muss doch
das primäre Augenmerk sein natürlich
haben wir sanitäre Verantwortung aber
wenn Menschen hier straffällig werden
und wenn sie ausreisepflichtig sind dann
müssen sie raus ganz einfach ja aber das
ist ja ein Schema nicht nur in Berlin
sondern es ist ja tatsächlich ein Schema
dass ich durchzieht seit vielen Jahren
in der Politik also ich komme aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen dort hatte schon
damals die Ministerpräsidentin Kraft
gesagt wir weisen grundsätzlich nicht
aus ja das heißt das ist ja eine
Einladung für Straftäter oder auch die
Einladung dazu auf diesen Staat zu
betrügen wenn ich weiß es gibt keine
Konsequenzen und da muss man ja auch
schauen was wir Menschen also was sind
das für junge Männer aus was für
Gesellschaften kommen die die verstehen
tatsächlich nur die kommen aus
hierarchisch sehr klaren autoritären
Strukturen und die setzen wir jetzt hin
und und wenn Sie einen Fehler machen
kriegen sie überhaupt gar keine
Konsequenz das heißt die Wissen egal was
ich mache mein Geld bekomme ich ich darf
bleiben und dieses Land ist so blöd die
behalten mich hier ja das heißt wir
kommen auch hier sie könnten kein Kind
so erziehen wie wir das hier machen ja
sondern wir müssen wir müssen uns an
unsere eigenen Regeln halten es geht gar
nicht darum dass man sagt wir brauchen
andere Regeln sondern wir müssen mit dem
gleichen Maß also messen und
psychologisch
dass wir das Aufbrechen in einer
Begleitung also diese Werte zu
vermitteln eine so starke Prägung eines
hierarchischen Systems lässt sich nicht
in drei Wochenenden aufbrechen das ist
ganz klar das ist ein Anspruch den man
dann Therapeut etwas gar nicht möglich
ist aber man muss sich deshalb bewusst
sein an welchem Punkt man tatsächlich da
da ansetzt und welche Gefährdung einfach
da ist und dass davor die Augen zu
verschließen macht für alle die
Situation unerträglich also es macht
auch für die für die 95% der Ferien die
nicht Strafe sind weil die allen eine
Tonne geworfen werden also ich spiele
seit vielen Jahrzehnten Fußball wenn man
die Geschichten sich anhört was
schwarzafrikanische Fußball Freunde von
mir erleben müssen weil sie die gleiche
Tonne geworfen werden dann ist das
erbittert sehr bitter und die sagen ist
die sagen ja selber es muss ein härtere
Gesetze und härtere Strafen her weil die
deutsche Polizei und der deutsche Staat
wird als lächerlich empfunden das
Problem ist bloß dabei sie wollen es
nicht ansprechen weil sie Angst haben
dadurch Hass und Rassismus zu schüren
aber genau das Gegenteil passiert in dem
sie mich nicht ansprechen wirkt es wie
vertuschen und dadurch fördern sie Hass
und Rassismus und unterstützen die
Parteien die keiner will ja also geht
offen damit um seht den Problemen die
Augen und handelt und setzt doch um der
Berlin ist der Sumpf des Versagens wie
gesagt Schluss Sache lächerliche Politik
hier übrigens haben sie betrogen weil
man nicht vergessen dann haben wir damit
aufgeklärt bei der Manipulation aber
entscheidend
meine Tochter ist 14 Jahre alt und ich
will dich hier gleich klarstellen wenn
das meiner Tochter angetan würde würde
ich die Welt aus den Angeln heben ich
ich habe nicht nicht die Politik ich
stehe an den Gräbern drauf ach
Beerdigung ich muss das hier lesen
die Menschen verzweifelt sich bei mir
melden und mich um Hilfe bitten weil sie
niemand mehr verkaufen weil ich ja
Politik oder eine Polizei teilweise das
macht auch was mit mir und das macht mir
stinksauer weil ich einfach nicht
verstehe dass man nicht schafft die
Menschen in unser Land zu schützen und
wo wir schon beim verdrängen sind wann
die Menschen hat den grünen ist steht
irgendwann auch nicht mehr dem deutschen
Volkes verbieten wir auch noch war den
deutschen Folge genau das heißt es alle
die in Deutschland sind sind das Volk
die Bürger im Land jeder Kultur aber
diese Politik ist links und auf grünen
Auge blind und folgt nur ihren Ding und
wenn es darum mich ständig geht in
Deutschland ist immer der gefährlicher
der die mich schnell anspricht anstatt
der die Michelle macht und zu
beantworten hat die Politik kriegt eine
mit Schuld und trägt Blut an ihren
Händen für diese Toten und es werden
mehr wenn wir nicht langsam endlich
aufwachen und Handeln ich glaube es gibt
durchaus Alternativen ich will noch ganz
kurze auf Frau Keller eingehen sie haben
ja die Politik von Rot Grün unter Frau
Kraft in NRW genannt der Nachfolger war
eine schwarz-gelbe Regierung mit einem
liberalen Innenminister nämlich
Handstand und da hat er eine radikale
Änderung wir haben konsequent
ausgewiesen wir haben konsequent auch
duldungs nicht mehr geduldete Personen
ausreisepflichtige Personen dort
zurückgeführt das ist eine alternative
es gibt auch konsequente und andere
Politik das muss man auch der Politik an
einigen Stellen mal zugute halten bei
allem Verständnis für das was Sie gesagt
haben so eine ganze offene Augen schauen
wir jetzt auf unser nächstes Thema die
Klima Kleber wir kennen sie sonst
Stahl hatte keiner was dabei gefallen
wieder ein bisschen runter zu kochen
aber ich glaube am nächsten Thema der
wird noch gerade angesprochen wir
sprechen jetzt über die Klima Kleber die
Aktivisten waren heute unterwegs
in München und in Berlin Birgit Keller
sitzt hier und sagt wir brauchen endlich
härtere Strafe Thema ja heute haben
wieder äh in München und in Berlin
Mitglieder der sogenannten letzten
Generation wobei man nur hoffen kann
dass das wirklich die letzte Generation
ist sich
illegal Zugang zum Flugfeld verschafft
mit dem Ziel den Flughafen Land zu legen
und ist auch zumindest in München mal
kurz geschafft
ich denke es ist an der Zeit dass wir
diese jungen Straftäter genauso
behandeln wie wir jeden anderen
Straftäter auch behandeln würden wir
schauen uns die ganze Zeit schon an was
sie treiben zuerst waren das
Straßenblockaden dann waren das Angriffe
Sachbeschädigung auf Kunstwerke jetzt
sind das die Flughäfen man fragt sich
was nehmen sie sich als nächstes vor auf
ihrer Homepage steht dass sie die
öffentliche Ordnung stören wollen
ansonsten stört das aber in unserer
Bundesregierung offensichtlich niemanden
weil wir reden immer noch von Aktivisten
und von klimarrettern nein das sind
Straftäter auf den gefährlichen Eingriff
in den Flugverkehr kriegt man
normalerweise Gefängnis und ich würde
sie alle Bitten zu überlegen was ihnen
eigentlich passieren würde wenn sie
morgen versuchen einen Flughafen zu
ändern mit dem Ziel in lahm zu legen wir
alle würde in den Bau gehen und genau
das denke ich sollten wir jetzt endlich
auch mit diesen Straftätern tun denn wir
würden es auch nicht dulden es geht
nicht um das Ziel es geht nicht darum
was sie eigentlich wollen denn wir
würden jeden Reichsbürger und jeden
Jungen rechtsradikalen würden wir
genauso in den Knast setzen und würden
nicht glauben heimliche Freude empfinden
also endlich alle Gesetze anwenden die
wir haben Herr Schall ich glaube wir
können offen darüber reden sie waren
kriminell in ihrer Jugend haben härtere
Strafen nicht festgeklebt aber ein
härtere Strafen sie abgehalten davon ist
das etwas was ein Appetit also es kommt
auch darauf wann du die härteren Strafen
erlebst umso und das ist nämlich das
entscheidende wenn du sie gleich früh
erlebst haben sie eine abschreckende
Wirkung wenn du aber lange damit
durchkommst dann lernst du im Knast nur
welche kennen mit denen du noch
Geschäfte planst bei denen ist es so
dass merkt man immer wieder dann geht's
vor allen Dingen um ihre eigene Wirkung
und wir klicken und da sind wir wieder
bei dem Thema linkes und grünes Auge
blickt das ist ja der verlängerte Arm
auf der grünen und ich frage mich ob sie
schon mehrfach gefordert wo ist
eigentlich die Distanzierung der Grünen
von dieser von diesen Herren und Damen
und immer wieder man muss sich
vorstellen was sind wir eigentlich für
eine Bananen Republik ich meine da
können die sich auf dem Flugzeug Platz
in einem Flughafen in Berlin und dort
Zutritt gewähren sie können sich da
feststellen sie können machen was sie
wollen und sie sagen ja wir werden immer
mehr machen nur noch mal zur Erinnerung
jetzt wurde hier gerade nicht gewartet
in Berlin ist eine Frau unter einen und
ein LKW geraten und die
Rettungsfahrzeuge kam zu spät ob sie
noch leben könnte oder nicht aber es
wurde gesagt es hat auf jeden Fall die
Zeit minimiert und einer dieser Gruppe
hat gesagt man wir sind hier im
klimakreb Kritik nicht Klima kuscheln ja
und da frage ich mich wo sollte
hinführen für mich sind Kriminelle ich
war kriminelle das ist kriminelle
Handlung man greift in die innere
Sicherheit ein und wenn ich dann aber
ein Herr Gisi der wird natürlich auch
natürlich ganz aus eigenem unnutzt tut
sich hinstellt und diese Leute da
vertritt und sagt setzen Sie ein Zeichen
sprechen Sie diese Leute frei die
kämpfen ja für die Freiheit und dann und
ich bin übrigens seit neuneinhalb Jahren
Aktivist ich habe noch so festgeklebt
habe keine innere Sicherheit bedroht
okay keine paar ausübt aber bei 995
Kinderschutz und dann waren die sich
Klima und Kinder in einem Atemzug zu
nehmen machen aber nichts gegen
Missbrauch machen nichts gegen Mobby und
Gewalt und da für die Zukunft der Kinder
wagt euch nicht die Kinder mit diesen
Dingen zusammen damit zu bringen ihr tut
ein Scheißdreck für die Kinder es geht
um euch und dann fahrt ihr noch mit
Autos dahin was für eine verlogene
Heuchlerei wen wollt ihr eigentlich
verarschen und noch mal vor Werdenberg
es sind ihre ideologischen Freunde ich
fordere Sie jetzt Außenministerin auf
und auch ein Hardeck hier endlich ist
Statement zu machen das wird nicht
wollte ist mir schon klar weil er
natürlich eure Wähler sind und die
wieder dranhängen aber es geht um die
innere Sicherheit ihr wolltet den Job
dann macht ihn oder legt dann am nieder
weil so fördert ihr innere Unsicherheit
und gefährdet unser Land alle durch weg
was sie zu sagen haben schauen wir mal
auf die Gründe warum man sich dort
habe ich jetzt leider hier gerade nicht
zu bieten
tue das weil die Regierung nicht genug
handelt die Regierung hat die Krise
nicht im Griff und alle anderen Methoden
sind leider ausgeführt ich habe auch
keine Lust das hier zu machen und ich
weiß dass viele Leute das nicht
verstehen werden aber wir haben keine
andere Wahl mehr
ich weiß auch dass ich hierfür
vielleicht auch wieder im Gefängnis
Lande wo ich vorher schon war wo jetzt
gerade vier Leute sind zwei davon bis
zum 5
und ich habe keine Lust Weihnachten im
Gefängnis zu bringen ich habe keine Lust
neuer im Gefängnis zu verbringen ich
möchte auch lieber bei meiner Familie
sein aber die Lage drängt
Herr Schmiel wenn Sie Malte zuhören
spüren sie da die Verzweiflung
vielleicht können Sie mal den Versuch
wagen und diese Generation zu erklären
also ferndiagnostik ist immer schwierig
an einem einzelnen Video Beleg mich
irritieren nur die Zahlen dass sie schon
wieder am 5 Januar draußen sind die über
die Erde gesprochen hat also halt also
das ist so natürlich ist diese
Generation verzweifelt natürlich hat
diese Generation auch ein emotionalen
Druck nur es war noch nie der Fall dass
die Schädigung von unbeteiligter zu
einer sinnvollen Diskussion führen das
funktioniert nicht das ist genauso wenn
man jetzt einfach weil man für ein
Kinderschutz Eintritt irgendwo hingehen
und ein paar Leuten vor die Klappe
halten oder andere Dinge verhindert das
hilft ja nicht für den Prozess und man
merkt ja auch ich bin selber kein Auto
finden viele Sachen inhaltlich passiert
toll aber man entwickelt ja eine
Antipathie plötzlich aufgrund dieser
Maßnahmen und deshalb kippt dieser
Prozess gerade in die falsche Richtung
deshalb kann man sagen überlegt euch
etwas was förderlich ist wo ihr das das
Wohlwollen der Gesellschaft auf euch
zieht anstelle sozusagen die Wut von
allen und wenn dann auch noch Menschen
Menschenleben dabei ums betroffen sind
dann ist ein Zeitpunkt gegeben da muss
einfach mit anderen Bedingungen
einhergegangen werden das Problem also
wenn ich dann höre es geht ja auch nicht
nur um die Bundesregierung die wo ich
denke eben die lassen das ja auch
gewähren weil sie klamm heimlich damit
auf sympathisieren weil man ja genau
genommen sozusagen hier diese Kinder
jetzt auf dem Rollfeld die Arbeit machen
um die Politik zu rechtfertigen die man
dann im Bundestag beschließen will mich
irritiert viel mehr wenn selbst der
Präsident ist Verfassungsschutzes
irgendwie sagt ja nee nee gegen die
gegen die letzte Generation muss man
eigentlich die muss man nicht beobachten
das sind ja nicht Extremisten ja also
wir haben jetzt gerade eine Woche hinter
uns wo wir irgendwie eine Rollstuhl
Armee ähm Ende 3000 Polizisten haben wir
ein paar Rentner in Maßanzügen verhaftet
irgendwie weil die anderen Bundestag
eventuell stürmen ist Wunder auch Waffen
gehören eine möglicherweise waren es
legale Waffen wir wissen noch nicht ob
das illegale Waffen ich will nur sagen
wir sind also ein Land das 3000
Polizisten in Gang setzt irgendwie um
einen um einen Royalisten der gerne sein
Reich zurückhaben möchte irgendwie
festzunehmen was halbgrenzwertig ist ich
verlange nur dass der Verfassungsschutz
sich dann bitteschön genauso mit einer
jungen Generation befasst die jetzt
schon bereit ist Sachbeschädigung zu
machen Hausfriedensbruch zu machen die
auf ihrer Homepage ankündigt dass sie
die öffentliche Ordnung stören will und
zwar so lange bis die Regierung das tut
was sie will Nötigung oder Pressung ist
das Nötigung oder Pressung Straftaten
die begangen werden und wir leben mit
einem Land wo man sagt ja da muss man
Verständnis haben nein sorry ich habe
null Verständnis ich habe übrigens in
einem Flieger gesessen als sie das erste
Mal an die er drin waren und ich habe
zwei Stunden im Flieger gesessen weil
die auf dem Rollfeld klebten und das
nächste mal irgendwie würde ich dir am
liebsten selber vom Rollfeld wieder
runterkratzen ich habe keinen
Verständnis und wir dürfen genau
genommen in einem Rechtsstand auch gar
nicht in dem Sinne mit Verständnis
arbeiten weil es nämlich egal ist aus
welcher Motivation heraus das passiert
wir sind vor dem Gesetz alle gleich ja
und wer eben wie soll ich sagen man muss
nur einmal theoretisch durch denken wenn
das jetzt nicht die klimakleber wären
auf dem Rollfeld sondern die
Reichsbürger während dann hier alle
genauso entspannt und wäre unsere
Regierung genauso entspannt wenn jetzt
plötzlich Reichsbürger mit ihrem
Rollator auf unserem Rollfeld auftauchen
und sagen wir machen den Putsch jetzt
auf dem Rollfeld nein dann wären alle so
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ja das heißt
wir wir messen auch hier wieder mit
zweierlei Maß weil mein heimlich
sympathisiert mit dieser Bewegung ja
während man an anderer Stelle mit aller
Härte des Gesetzes Durchgang auch hier
sage ich ich will gar keine
Sonderbehandlung ich will dass die
Sonderbehandlung aufhört wir wollen hier
ja vor allem auch verstehen warum
Menschen sowas machen warum sie diesen
Weg wählen keine ganzen Probleme haben
keine ernsten Probleme also muss man
wirklich sagen das ist wenn man sich die
Sorgen anguckt die Nummer die
Klimaentwicklung aus Sicht dieser
Generation mit sich bringt und sie das
Gefühl haben die Versäumnisse der
Politik wenn man bestimmte Ziele
vereinbart die gemeinsam vereinbart
werden und Ziele sind nie erreicht
werden und alle Bemühungen nicht ernst
genommen werden dass dann jemand auf die
Straße geht das haben wir als wir gegen
die Abrüstung also für die Abrüstung
demonstrieren wir auch auf die Straße
gegangen und haben uns sichtbar gemacht
aber du hast du hast eine Demo
angemeldet das war alles legal das Recht
haben
das ist zum Beispiel ich mache das neun
Jahre Kinderschutz wenn ich mich auf der
Straße festgeklebt hätte oder sonst seid
ihr macht das ich wäre sofort im Bau
gegangen hätten Exempel statuiert dass
ich mir nie wieder wage ich finde es
okay dass sie sich feststellen täglich
am Bundestag fest klebt dich an
Lauterbach oder Scholz Fest hat dann
morgen sowieso wieder vergessen mach
bitte aber lass die hört auf mit der
Nötigung ihr wolltet klimaschützen dann
hat die Leute auf zu erpressen ihr nötig
die Menschen und der Hass wird steigen
ist wie mit dem gleichen ist wenn sie
nicht darüber reden welche fehlende
Migration hier stattfindet und Kirche
gefahren sind fördern sie damit hast
wenn sie tot schweigen und genau das ist
das hier aber es ist der verlängerte
gerätearm der Grünen und deswegen wird
es toleriert zu erreichen Sie die
Menschen noch erreichen Sie die die sich
auf die Straße geben kleben die wie Herr
Schmid sagt die Hoffnung das Vertrauen
die Perspektive verloren hat also ich
glaube die die auf der Straße kleben die
erreicht die Politik nicht das ist ja
auch verständlich die wollen ja
selbstverständlich das ist eine kleine
Gruppe muss man ja sagen von 30 sehr
stark radikalisierten Personen und die
wird man auch nicht erreichen die muss
man eben mit rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln
auch in den Griff bekommen das ist ähm
ja Moment es ist nicht ganz also ich
wenn man also sich auf die Straße klebt
und sagt ich verlange von der Politik
dass sie einen Busticket bundesweit für
9 € einführt ja und und bis es fertig
ist klebe ich mich nicht los ja das geht
einfach nicht das jeder weiß dass sowas
nicht funktioniert weil dann setzt sich
der nächste und ich will kostenlos Bier
und ich will Äpfel und ich hätte gern
ein Haus für 9 €, das wird nicht
funktioniert deswegen muss ja auch die
Politik da durchgreifen wir haben zwei
ganz einfache Vorschläge gemacht das
eine ist was am ersten Mai gut
funktioniert das Verfahren manche von
diesen Tätern haben schon 30 Mal geklebt
bis jetzt 30 Leute sind 30 Mal gesehen
warum sind heute wieder zwei
flughäfenlauben der Punkt weil eben
keine beschleunigten Verfahren
durchgeführt werden so dass man die auch
mal bei Wiederholungstaten etwas länger
in Haft nehmen könnte beispielsweise ja
es geht ja darum einmal strafrechtlich
gegen sie vorzugehen und dann der zweite
Vorschlag den auch die FDP gemacht hat
war wir wollen eine
schadensersatzplattform wo die Bürger
das sind ja hunderttausende die jeden
Tag davon betroffen sind und die Bürger
die materielle Schäden erleiden z.B weil
sie mit dem mit dem Mietwagen gerade
weiß ich von einem Carsharing fliegen
können wenn sie den gewohnt haben
Geschäftstermin verpassen ähnliches da
entstehen Kosten und die müssten durch
so eine Plattform wie bei
Fluggastrechten einfach geltend gemacht
werden können das könnten nicht alle
machen aber das wären vielleicht pro
Stau 20 30.000 € und dann würden nämlich
die Finanzströme die momentan eben das
ganze tragen weil die kriegen ja auch
noch Geld aus Inland und Ausland die
sammeln Spenden und darüber finanziert
sich das alles das müsste man sich
ansehen das wäre ganz dringend nur das
Problem ist wir haben bei Grünen und
Linken da beißen wir auf Granit an der
Stelle in Berlin ein rot-grün-roter
Senat haben überhaupt kein Interesse
daran beschleunigt das Verfahren
schadensersatzplattform alles abgelehnt
und das ist das Problem wir brauchen ein
konsequentes Vorgehen die Vorschläge
liegen auf dem Tisch man könnte es auch
machen aber es wird Stillschweigen
toleriert und das geht nicht genau das
ist aber das einzige das ist in genau
das Kernproblem ist es wird toleriert ja
wir haben sozusagen es gibt genug oder
zu viele Leute in diesem Land die
Verständnis haben dafür und deswegen
eben und genau darauf können die auch
bauen und genau genommen irgendwie es
lohnt gar nicht darüber zu diskutieren
ob die reden wollen weil genau genommen
wenn die reden wollten dann würden die
dann würden sie schauen dass sie sich in
den demokratischen Prozess einteilen
einschalten aber genau das tun sie auch
nicht ja also um den lieben malte zu
zitieren der sagt alle anderen Methoden
sind ausgeschöpft welche Methoden bitte
schön hat in der Liebe malte schon
ausgeschöpft ja ähm was kommt danach
nein nein nein
teilweise Entwicklung der 70er Jahren
der RAF so hat übrigens der liebe Herr
Müller Tacho Müller auch gesagt wir
haben so ein bisschen verniedlich als
grüne RAF so verniedlich wenn man solche
Dinge schon hört frage ich mich wohin
soll das führen und genau davor was ist
denn das nächste Ziel wie radikalisieren
sich dann und dann sagt der
Verfassungsschutz ist schlimm oder Herr
Gisi um sich selbst zu profilieren
profilieren sagt oh sprechen sie mein
Grundsatz Urteil die sind doch gar nicht
so böse aber wisst er nur nebenbei
marceloute ich und tischis haben wir
dafür gesorgt das sind Berlin neuwahlen
sind ja aber dafür gesorgt dass die
Demokratie geschützt wird das kam mir
jetzt alles raus also haben wir ja in
Berlin die Möglichkeit neu zu wählen und
vielleicht kapiert jetzt der eine oder
andere der nicht gewählt hat oder der
vielleicht denkt durchlebt wenn man
anders dass man jetzt in Berlin einen
solchen Tod Schweiger und kriminellen
Unterstützer sehen hat der nicht mal
seine Opfer entschädigt von
Kindesmissbrauch wo sie sich 30 Jahre
mit schuldig gemacht haben entschädigt
vielleicht mal anders wird wenn nur ein
kleiner Hinweis ist wir haben ja genug
dafür getan um die Demokratie zu
schützen das hier ist eine Gefährdung
der Demokratie und nochmal linkes Auge
und grünes Auge blind wir machen den
Mund auf es reicht und wir atmen einmal
ganz kurz durch und dann fragen wir uns
wie geht es ihnen eigentlich wie geht es
Ihnen ja mindestens jeder fünfte
Deutsche steht für psychischen
Herausforderungen wir ziehen einmal im
Tisch hierdurch
das gleich unser Thema kurzen Pause bis
gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht wollen hier ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner sagt ehrlich gesagt ist das
fast total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten und wir uns gegenseitig
in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos verkaufen
das funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles essen als
freiheitlicher Mensch würde ich sagen
das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und umierungen von
Menschen unser Land fordert dann müsst
ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch was
machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über dem Gerät
[Musik]
die einzelnen Arbeitsplatz der Krieg die
Preise die explodieren wir haben alle
genug Gründe uns richtig Sorgen zu
machen und ganz vielen geht es auch
wirklich ans Herz und an die Seele Rolf
Schmied ist bei uns und er sagt
tatsächlich sind immer mehr Deutsche vor
ganz großen Herausforderungen wie geht
es Deutschland und vor allem was können
wir tun um wieder mehr Lebensfreude zu
bekommen
wir stehen vor einer großen
Herausforderung mittlerweile kann man
sagen dass mindestens jeder fünfte
Deutsche tatsächlich psychisch
herausgefordert ist instabil ist und das
wirkt sich auf verschiedenste Art und
Weise aus das heißt wir können
feststellen dass gerade die Kleinsten
der Kleinen da wird gleich Carsten Star
wahrscheinlich auch was zu sagen können
darunter massiv bleiben noch nie in
unserer Geschichte in Deutschland waren
Jugend und Kinderpsychiatrie so
überlaufen in Zeiten des corona-wahns
gab es nur eine einzige Triage in
Deutschland die fand in dem Psychiatrie
statt man musste schon mit Selbstmord
drohen um tatsächlich eingeliefert oder
aufgenommen zu werden aber es kümmert
sich da keiner drum wir müssen uns
selber darum kümmern Gott sei Dank
gibt's aus psychologischer Sicht immer
wieder Chancen was wir für uns tun
können damit wir resilient und
widerstandsfähig bleiben egal wie groß
der Wahnsinn um uns herum ist
gehen wir da einmal direkt rein wo ist
der Unterschied für mich wenn ich sage
oh ich bin seit längerer Zeit schlecht
drauf wann passiert aber dieser Punkt
dass man sich eingestehen sollte ich bin
reif für eine Behandlung ich brauche
wirklich hilfe es gibt so einfachen Test
das ist ein einfacher Test wo man sich
selber fragen kann oder wenn man das bei
jemand beobachtet gerade wenn es um
Depression so depressive Episoden geht
wie sehr war das in den letzten 14 Tagen
am Stück das heißt hast du den letzten
14 Tagen Interessen die ich sonst
begeistert haben aus den Augen verloren
hast du den letzten 14 Tagen mit
niemanden mehr gelacht bist du seit 14
Tagen in diesem Zustand dann wird es
wirklich gefährlich dann muss man
dringend Hilfe einholen aber ich finde
es immer so Wahnsinn dass wir so lange
warten bis es so schlimm wird das heißt
in dem Moment wo ich merke ich stehe mit
einem anderen wir sind alle so extrem
gereizt und das liegt daran dass unsere
Gesellschaft wirklich viele
Herausforderung mit sich bringt aber wir
im Alltag und ziemlich dumm benehmen und
nichts dafür tun dass es uns besser geht
also mein wichtiger Tipp ist anstelle
sich auf Instagram Bilder anzugucken
besorgt immer wieder ein Bildband oder
ein Familienalbum und setz dich mal mit
allen hin und nimm dir Zeit in Ruhe was
zu machen diese Entschleunigung einfach
mal diese emotionalen Trigger emotionale
Reize sind das runterzufahren umso
weniger emotionale Reize ich zulasse im
Alltag umso mehr Zeit ich mir für mich
nehme umso souveräner kann ich sein also
ich will ein Beispiel aufgreifen ich
kann Carsten da sehr gut verstehen dass
er da kocht in jeder Diskussion ist es
aber schwierig wenn ich nicht in der
Souveränität in der Ruhe bleibe einen
anderen tatsächlich für MICH zu gewinnen
das heißt wenn ich berechtigt in einer
Partnerschaft oder im Familienkreis
genervt bin und dann aber drüber schieße
für das immer zu einer
Eskalationsspirale besser ist es in
solchen Situation so Psycho Hacks so
nenne ich das ja Methoden zu kennen wie
ich mich runter fahre mich selbst
beruhige und dann souverän nach vorne zu
gehen auch souveräne Forderungen zu
stellen aber eben nicht in dieser
wahnhaftigkeit und in dieser teilweise
wir erleben das im Straßenverkehr immer
mehr überall sind immer mehr Aggression
immer mehr Gewalt und aus meiner Sicht
gibt es ein großes Versäumnis in der
Politik weil sich keiner darum kümmert
zu sehen unser Gesellschaft geht es
nicht gut aber wo wird am ersten
gestrichen in der sozialen Arbeit in der
Betreuung von von von von Jugendlichen
dort ist kein Geld für da und wenn wir
uns um die nicht kümmern kommen noch
viel härtere Zeiten auf uns zu es ist
immer die Politik das kenn
wahrscheinlich schon aber Frau Kelle ist
es vielleicht auch dieses dass man
zurück findet zur Familie zu
Kraftquellen wie Herr Schmiedes auch
gesagt hat wieder in diese Geborgenheit
reinzukommen Familien gezeigt zu
genießen verlernen wir das so ein Stück
weit na sagen wir es mal so es bleibt
für viele wenig Zeit dafür also die wenn
wir wir sind ja in einer Gesellschaft wo
zunehmend auch beide Eltern berufstätig
sein müssen um die Familie zu ernähren
das heißt einerseits drängt man die
Menschen in diese doppelte
Berufstätigkeit dann hat keiner mehr für
die Kinderzeit die Kinder sind sozusagen
ein Wachsen eigentlich eher in peer
groups groß was in dem Sinne eine
gefährliche Kiste ist in bestimmten
Altersklassen weil dort das rechte
Stärkeren gilt ja das heißt diese Kinder
sind im Prinzip ungeschützt wenn nicht
Erwachsene das quasi überblicken was
mich stört ist eben aber auch
grundsätzlich eine Politik die
eigentlich nie in die Ursachen geht also
es ist ja einerseits sagen wir mal
stellen wir fest okay wir haben jetzt
ganz viele Kinder vor allen Dingen im
Kinder und Jugendliche die gerade durch
die corona-krise noch mal massiv
gelitten haben wir haben aber schon das
wussten wir schon die drei Monaten und
schon damals hat man es schlicht
ignoriert also was mich immer stört ist
so wir Kitten jetzt Probleme die wir gar
nicht hätten haben müssen anstatt dass
man einfach sagt wir reden immer alle
über Kinderrechte über was weiß ich
alles und faktisch tun wir gar nichts
dafür ja wir haben noch nicht einmal
abgesichert das sollte wieder
irgendetwas wie lockdowns kommen dass
dann die Schulen bitte aufbleiben ich
habe vier Kinder ja und ich habe im
Lockdown erlebt wie man meinen Kindern
sämtliche Freizeitmöglichkeiten genommen
hat wie man ihn in die Schule genommen
hat wie man ihn verboten hat sich mit
ihren Freunden zu treffen die man sogar
die Sportvereine zugemacht hat und die
Spielplätze abgesperrt hat ja und dann
wundert man sich das Kinder psychisch
krank werden wenn man ihnen ihr ganzes
Leben wegnimmt ja und das sind einfach
so Dinge und man hat das mit einer
Leichtigkeit getan hat man den jungen
Kindern hat man aufgebürdet sie sollen
im Namen der Gesundheit der älteren
Generation sollten die Kinder
zurückstecken anstatt dass es andersrum
ist anstatt das ist andersrum wir sind
für die Gesundheit ihre Kinder zuständig
und wir müssten alles dafür tun dass
Kinder Kinder sein dürfen
wie warst du das mit deinen Kindern also
erstmal meist ja nicht nur mit meinen
Kindern sondern es ist genau das es ist
ja das was ich tagtäglich war gestern
erst in Löbau und in der Schule mit 600
Schülern ich hatte über 100.000 Schüler
genau deshalb vor dem ersten Lockdown
habe ich am Sparen und auch ein lauter
machen doch andere gewarnt wenn wir die
Kinder aus der Schule nehmen aus dem
Verein und auch aus den Kitas dann
werden wir noch nie da gewesen der
Zahlen haben noch nie da gewesen
Missbrauch noch nie der ganze Gewalt und
die suizidschan werden extrem die hör
schon wir haben eine Suizidrate von 400
gehabt die hatten über 6 %
heißen da machen wir eine Sondersendung
zu dass aber was entscheiden wir sagen
das und dann kommt er und sagt wer gar
nicht nötig gewesen entschuldigt sich
aber wir haben den Kindern so viel Leid
angetan über ihre Rücken unserer Kinder
und genau das was er gesagt hat wir
machen immer wieder weiter und wir wir
lernen nicht daraus was habe ich im
Moment dieselben Fehler immer und immer
wieder das ist etwas was wir wirklich in
die Gesundheit so beobachten ja ich will
aber noch zu Ihnen kommen wir haben
nicht mehr viel Zeit ich sage es ehrlich
aber es ist ein wichtiges Thema weil
dieselben Fehler oder zumindest ein
Thema was überhaupt nicht funktioniert
heute war großer warntag um 11 Uhr
sollten überall diese regenschein weil
ich überall der Fall und sie sagen zum
Glück war das nur eine Probe absolut wir
haben im Katastrophenschutz gesehen
heute der warntag in vielen
Bundesländern hat es nicht geklappt mit
den Warnungen in manchen besser in
Berlin beispielsweise keine einzige
Sirene hat auch geholt weil eben nur 28
400 Standorten besetzt waren aber die 28
waren nicht angeschlossen dann haben wir
das Problem dass natürlich nicht nur die
Warnung selber problematisch ist sondern
es muss auch davor was passieren die
Selbsthilfe Fähigkeit in der Bevölkerung
muss hergestellt werden und auch nach
einer Warnung muss eine Katastrophe
bewältigt werden und auch da liegt der
Hase im Pfeffer denn die Behörden sind
auf Katastrophen nicht mehr vorbereitet
wir haben das im Alter gesehen wir sehen
das immer wieder gerade in den großen
Städten ist die Koordination
mangelhaft und wir können wirklich von
Glück sein ich darf das hier nur mal
betonen dass das diesmal noch keine
echte Katastrophe war denn dann wird es
wirklich haarig für Deutschland ich will
nicht mit seiner schlechten Nachricht
aus der Sendung gehen sie müssen uns
einmal noch nachliefern was passieren
muss wann wird's klappen doch nicht erst
in Berlin haben sie glaube ich gesagt
2024 bitte sagen sie dass das nicht sein
kann
ja das ist jetzt sehr schwierig also ich
sag mal eine Minute habe ich auf morgen
fliegt ja wir haben einen Senat der sich
um die Prioritäten nicht kümmert und es
braucht eine Politik die anfängt sich
damit zu beschäftigen wie wir die
Probleme in den Griff bekommen FDP hat
ein ganz klaren Vorschlag gemacht diese
organisierte Verantwortungslosigkeit die
wir beispielsweise in Berlin haben einen
Senat der sagt die Bezirke sind schuld
das in Katastrophenschutz nichts
passiert
nein da muss man eine ganz radikale
Reform machen wir müssen in Berlin
beispielsweise so eine einstufigen
Verwaltung kommen wo diese elenden
Bezirksämter wegkommen wo man einfach
sagt es gibt auch einen der am Ende
verantwortlich ist oder eine die am Ende
verantwortlich ist die verantwortlich
handelt ihre Verantwortung auch
übernimmt grundsätzliches Problem gerade
im Katastrophenschutz ganz ganz wichtig
dass da in Deutschland was passiert weil
unsere Katastrophenschutzbehörden haben
30 Jahre jetzt Friedensdividende und so
weiter ist leider aufgebraucht viel zu
wenig Aufmerksamkeit
wenn wir ein Blackout haben dann wird es
auch mit der Warnung schwierig weil die
Sirenen ja nicht funktionieren ja
ich hatte die eigentlich angezündet für
die Opfer aber wahrscheinlich zünde ich
die gerade für unser Land an weil es
wird bald dunkel werden und wenn man das
hört ganz ehrlich für diesen Berliner
Senat und diese Versagen hilft keine
Kerze mehr da hilft nur Neuwahlen und
ich hoffe dass wir in einem Ernstfall
alle geschützt sind aber wir sollten mal
bei den Bürgern anfangen langsam
aufzuschreiben und zu sagen bis hier und
nicht weiter das ist doch nicht wirklich
unser Land was ihr abläuft Unfähigkeit
hoch zehn muss ich einfach sagen von
Carsten Stahl und damit bedanke ich mich
ganz herzlich bei meinen Gästen wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Tag wir sehen
uns wieder nächsten Dienstag herzlichen
Dank fürs zuschauen bis dann
[Musik]